Analysts turned to
historical aircraft
designs for clues to the
monster plane's purpose.
There's a really deep
history in aviation of
building gigantic
aircraft that pushed the
limits of what we think
is possible.
And the most iconic of
these is the Spruce
Goose.
The colossal 320 foot
wingspan.
Spruce Goose is followed
three decades later by
the Antonov 225, which
holds the world record
for the biggest ever
payload equivalent to 45
African elephants. But
the aircraft in the image
has a very different
design from these monster
planes.
The Antonov has a very
large fuselage to carry
large amounts of stuff.
When we look at our
mystery aircraft, it has
two fuselages, both of
which are very skinny.
It looks more like it's
built to carry something
underneath the aircraft.